Paul mana forts former right hand man
will testify again this morning and his
ex bosses fraud trial mana forts lawyers
hammered gates yesterday calling him a
liar and getting him to admit on the
stand to cheating on his wife and
stealing from Paul man afford this
morning they'll continue their attack on
gates who's cooperating with Special
Counsel Robert Muller's investigation
Paula Reed is outside the courthouse in
Alexandria Virginia Paula good morning
good morning I was inside the courtroom
yesterday and you could see that Gates
was visibly nervous under this
relentless questioning from defense
attorneys and while he was on the stand
he revealed new details about other
crimes he may have committed while he
was a member of the Trump transition he
says he may have embezzled from the
inauguration fund in a dramatic exchange
meant affords attorney Kevin downing a
skates after all the lies you told and
fraud you've committed you expect this
jury to believe you yes gates responded
I'm here to tell the truth a Democrat
inspired witch-hunt I would call it the
rig to witch-hunt President Trump has
continuously tried to discredit the
Muller probe and paints its first
official trial as a case of overzealous
prosecution Paul Manafort who's that who
really is a nice man and man affords
lawyers hope the jury will also see the
former Trump campaign chairman as a
victim under relentless
cross-examination Gates admitted to
embezzling from mana for as well as more
sordid details like having an
extramarital affair a decade ago along
with the secret apartment in London to
house the tryst Gates testified that he
committed financial crimes including tax
evasion and bank fraud at mana forts
direction the trial focused on the Trump
campaign for the first time yesterday as
gates admitted that quote it's possible
he may have submitted personal expenses
to the inaugural committee it's very
likely that Gates knows a great deal of
what was going on in the campaign former
federal prosecutor Peters iton berg says
gates cooperation with the special
counsel could lead to more indictments
in the probe there will be other shoes
to drop in this investigation
Gate said that he falsified these
financial documents because mana fort
was upset about how much he owed in
taxes in one email shown to the jury
gates revealed to mana for just how much
he owed mana fort replied WTF
how could I be blindsided like this
Viana as Gale said at the top of the
show a real-life telenovela happening
there in the courtroom Paula thank you